you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webcast next generation sequencing
for brca1 and brca2 mutation testing my
name is June van and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots for
more information please visit lab roots
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the live Q&A event you can submit
questions by typing them in in the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please confirm
the support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem to the green Q&A button lower
left and now a brief note on about Cajun
our sponsor for today's web event
hygiene is the leading global provider
of sample to inside solutions to
transform biological materials into
valuable molecular insights hygiene
sample technologies isolate and process
DNA RNA and proteins from blood tissue
and other materials assay technologies
make these biomolecules visible and
ready for analysis bioinformatics
software and knowledge bases interpret
data to report relevant actionable
insights automation solutions tie these
together in seamless and cost-effective
molecular testing workflows konjam
provides these workflows to more than
500,000 customers around the world in
molecular diagnostics apply testing
Pharma and academia and now I would like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Riya
Samara dr. Sian Brian Samara is the
global product manager responsible for
next-generation sequencing at hydrogen
before this he was scientist in the
arcade project project management
department of hydrogen at Frederick when
he manages and Courtney
multiple life sciences product
development projects across our date and
operation teams prior to joining
hydrogen he was a postdoctoral fellow at
the National Cancer Institute conducting
research in the field of cancer
immunology with emphasis on identifying
strategies to boost efficacy of cancer
vaccines received his PhD degree from
Georgetown University in tumor biology
and will now turn over to dr. Ryan
samara for his presentation thank you
soon and just a couple of legal
disclaimers before I get into this
webinar the chitin products shown in
this webinar are intended for molecular
biology applications only these products
are not intended for the diagnosis
prevention or treatment of a disease and
for up-to-date licensing information and
product specific disclaimers please see
the respective kaijin kit handbook or
user manual all of these handbooks or
user manuals can be found at wkin com
okay so as an outline for today's
webinar first I will go through an
introduction on bracket one and bracket
two genes just to give you a general
background and then I will introduce to
you the sample to incite solution that
collision has built for next-generation
sequencing challenges then I will go
through some performance and
applications data i will give you two
examples one for the application of
routine testing and then the second one
is for the application of biomarker
studies for Disease stratification and
clinical trials and then I will close
this off with a summary so on to the
first topic introduction to bracha one
or bracket two genes
so it is known that blackra1n bracket 2
jeans are key tumor suppressor genes
they have DNA repair and transcriptional
regulation functions their importance is
highlighted in breast cancer we all know
that mutations in bracket 1 and bracket
2 genes can predispose both females and
males to the development of breast
cancer as a matter of fact around point
two five percent of us women carry a
mutation in bracket one bed in some
bracket genes this translates to around
three hundred and seventy-five thousand
cases a year and these mutations will
will put these individuals at a very
high risk for hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer bracken mutations are
associated with forty to eighty percent
lifetime breast cancer risk and they are
associated with about eleven to forty
percent lifetime of ovarian cancer risk
now the the importance of bracket one
and bracket to mutational testing is is
highlighted by the fact that knowledge
of the of the risks of breast cancer and
ovarian cancer allows us to prevent
those diseases and also knowledge of the
mutational status of bracket one hand
bracket to can also help us in optimize
disease management and i will give you
again an example of how how those
studies can be used in clinical trials
so for bracket 1 and bracket 2 there has
been new recent developments the bracha
one bracket 2 mutational status has been
studied in breast cancer and the effects
of a PARP inhibitor drug known as a lot
prev known as elaborate has been shown
to as maintenance therapy to be
associated with with increased
progression-free survival versus placebo
in patients with platinum sensitive
recurrent ovarian cancer so those
patients who have shown mutations in
their bra kohinoor bracket to genes
respond more favorably to the back to
the parp inhibitor than those with
withdrawal type bracha 1 and bracket 2
and this is clearly shown in the in this
paper that was published
late late last year so the when when the
authors of this study looked at the
response of patients of all patients
versus Braca mutated patients versus
Brock unmutated patients to this to this
part inhibitor otherwise known as
elaborate they did see that there is an
increase in the response rate in in
those patients in which bracha one
bracket to our loot ated compared to
those patients in which bracket one in
bracket to our unmutated indicating that
mutations in specifically in bracket one
in bracket to which belong to these you
know the tumor suppressor genes and
involved in DNA repair machinery
mutations in these in these jeans will
allow those patients to respond more
favorably to inhibitors of parp and and
so this this was really a key study that
highlighted the importance of looking at
the mutations of bracha one end bracket
to in in ovarian cancer specifically but
as i will show you in later on this
webinar you can actually see that two
mutations in bracha one and bracket 2 as
well as other key tumor suppressor genes
and genes are involved in DNA repair are
also important for for the same for the
response of the same against the same
drug in prostate cancer patients as well
and because of these of these results
this this elaborate a drug received a
positive opinion in the you because of
its efficacy in ovarian cancer so on to
the sample to incite solution that
collision has built for next-generation
sequencing challenges so i mentioned
that the the mutational status of bracha
1 and bracket 2 are important to know
from a both a a therapeutic perspective
as well as for from from an
understanding the underlying mechanisms
of a disease perspective and so but but
we know that to use next-generation
sequencing for studying the mutational
status of bracket 1 beta 2 and other and
other G's as well to is very challenging
because there are a lot of challenges
associated with the next-generation
sequencing workflow
from from sample preparation to to data
analysis and what I will go through next
is the sample to incite solution that
Kayden has built to address these
challenges so kyon has built this
Universal workflow from sample to
insight to overcome NGS challenges I
broken down the NGS workflow into six
individual modules if I may call them
and three individual QC modules as well
and what I've done here is listed the
the challenges associated with each one
of these modules on just to kind of give
you an example of what it takes and what
kinds of challenges you will go through
along the way so it all starts with
sample isolation sample isolation can be
followed by targeted enrichment if you
are interested in in undertaking a
targeted DNA sequencing approach this is
where you enrich your sample for
specific genes or specific regions of
interest as opposed to a whole genome or
a whole exome approach where you're
either looking at every single base in
the genome or you're looking at
specifically the you know specifics on
coding regions of the genome this is
followed by the library construction
step that's where we construct libraries
from those regions that we have we have
enriched in the targeted enrichment step
followed by the NGS run and then that
analysis and interpretation this is also
a major challenge there's a lot of data
that gets generated through from from
NGS runs these data have to be on have
to be analyzed and also interpreted the
interpretation step means just what you
know if you find a mutation in a
specific gene what does it mean for
Maria logical and clinical perspective
so so again this is just a breakdown a
general overview of the workflow
associated with with almost any NGS run
for targeted enrichment now when it
comes to challenges there are a lot of
challenges as you can see here for
sample isolation there's the challenge
of isolating high-quality DNA samples so
we know that DNA can come from many
different types of samples and a lot of
a lot of researchers use FFPE samples
and you know that the DNA quality of the
of these samples is extremely low you
can end up with with very highly
fragmented DNA and you can end up with
very low amounts of DNA so this brings
me to the second challenge for sample
isolation which is quantifying amplifier
bull not bulk amounts of DNA because PCR
is used in almost every step of this
workflow you want to make sure that the
DNA that you're using is amenable to
amplification by pcr a lot of the
methods as you will see throughout this
webinar a lot of the methods just
quantify both amounts of DNA the main
challenge here is that if you only amp
if you only quantify the bulk announcer
viene you might be actually
overestimating the amplifier amounts of
DNA that you have in your sample because
some of that DNA might not actually be
amplifier through PCR in this workflow
for the targeted enrichment step the
main challenges our turnaround time and
limited amounts of DNA you don't want
they targeted interaction step that
takes days to finish and you also want
to be able to enrich your targets with
using very limited amounts of DNA again
going back to the FFPE example if you
have you know a couple of slices of DNA
how much a couple of slices of the
sample how much of how much DNA can you
actually isolate from these samples it's
going to be very limited so you want a
target to the enrichment approach that
allows you to use these limited amounts
of DNA when it comes to library
construction the main challenge is
library yield and in the different the
multiple steps that are needed for
library construction i will show you how
this sample to incite solution has has
addressed these challenges for the NGS
run each each platform has its own
specific challenges I'm not going to go
through it to go through these
challenges in this in this presentation
or webinar there are a lot there's a lot
of material on the web that you can
check out if you're interested in one
platform versus the other for that
analysis again there's a lot of
information a lot of date data that gets
generated from next-generation
sequencing analyzing this data is a
major challenge because all these other
reads that are coming off of
sequence or have to be appropriately
mapped and aligned and then variants
have to be called off of these reads the
interpretation part is also challenging
because you have a lot of mutations that
get detected in these samples and the
the challenge here is is to identify
those that are actionable versus not
actionable which ones can you act upon
which ones can you not act upon or you
do not have information enough
information to act upon so again this
presents another challenge so what I
will go to through today is to is to
show you how this sample to incite
solution addresses some of these
challenges along the the mgs workflow
and also along the along that workflow
will be I will be talking about specific
products that that Kayden has developed
that will fit into the individual
modules and again remember all of these
kits that I will be mentioning today are
from molecular biology applications only
so starting off with challenging samples
or DNA from challenging samples just to
kind of give you an example of FFPE
samples we know that the use of DNA
isolated from ffpe tissues remains a
major challenge why because the quality
of DNA is very low from FFPE samples
there's a lot of base damage because of
the preservation process and this ends
up with an increased rate of false
positives there are many papers out
there that have that have described
these artifacts and these challenges
this is one of them was published in BMC
medical genomics if you're interested in
accessing it it is freely available on
the web and it talks about the
challenges of of using FFPE samples so
what kyon has has done is it has
developed the GE DNA ffpe get the g read
DNA ffpe kit enzymatically removes
artifacts during be any isolation steps
and provides more confidence in snip
calling or variant calling so it
actually it physically and enzymatically
it removes these these artifacts that
you can see in FFPE samples what this
translates to is is improved accuracy in
variant calling and I will show
an example on the next step another
feature of this of this kit is that it
can be automated on the kayak you to
streamline your process so here's an
example of how this kit can can be used
and in the value that it carries so so
what you're looking at here is some
variants that have been detected in 15
FFPE samples these are actually not 15
these this is a one sample but it's 15
years old it is a 15 year old liver
carcinoma ffpe sample so the sample was
isolated or the DNA from this sample was
isolated by two different methods either
the cayenne ffpe kit or the gene we'd
ffpe kid that that enzymatically removes
these these false positives once the DNA
was was isolated what we did is we
enriched a hundred and sixty genes that
are heavily implicated in cancer using
BG read comprehensive cancer panel we
constructed libraries on to be sequenced
on an Illumina platform specifically
them I seek so what you're looking at
here are the different variants that
have been detected in some of these
genes in this 15 year old liver cancer a
sample specifically ffpe sample and what
you see in the in the red and green
cells are those mutations that have been
corrected for by the gene read ffpe kit
we know that these are false positives
that have been corrected for by the
enzymatic remover of these artifacts in
the g reat ffpe kit so if you look at
this c 2 t an invitation that was seen
using cayenne pepper PE kit you do not
see that mutation now in the gene read
ffe kit and this is true for some for
some of the mutations for you know cpt
mutation or 32 a mutation as well
however we know that not all of the g2 a
or c 2 t mutations are our force a
negative is I mean some of them are true
positives and you actually see some you
see those types of mutations not being
corrected for because they are true
positives however for those ones that
are not true positives you see them
being corrected for so this is just an
example of how the enzymatic removal of
these artifacts can actually increase
your accuracy of
variant calling in your sfv examples now
another challenge as I mentioned is is
the quantification of DNA so not all DNA
that you will isolate from your samples
is amplified by and is functional in in
the NGS workflow so the inaccurate
quantification of input DNA is a major
challenge because it can lead to poor
target enrichment in NGS library yield
eventually leading to wastage of your
precious samples and time and also a
wastage of your of your money because
you just spent your sequencing run on
DNA that cannot be sequenced so to
highlight this this challenge I just
kind of want to touch upon a couple of
of ways by through which DNA is is
usually quantified on the the two major
and most commonly used methods espect
spectrum spectrophotometry and
fluorometry um spectrophotometry
measures any form of DNA were loyal
fluorometry can measure double-stranded
DNA that you know down to 20 paces now
while these are very helpful for for
specific samples the the quantification
by these methods can be a major
challenge simply because what you are
measuring or is both amount of DNA you
are not measuring the amplifier bow
amounts of DNA that are present in your
samples you're just basically taking a
look at every single form of DNA that
exists in these samples again this is a
challenge because the non amplify abul
DNA is not going to be able to
participate in you know the different
steps of the NGS workflow one way around
this is to use qpcr we know that qpcr is
is very accurate and it gives you a good
representation of the amount of
amplifier both DNA that is present in
your sample we have taken advantage of
qpcr and developed the GRE DNA quantum
eyes kit to specifically address this
challenge it is a it is a Q pcr-based
kit that measures amplify herbal or
functional DNA with by using this this
is this kit you can actually get a good
sense of how much of that DNA that is
present in your sample can be
/ by pcr and can be translated to
library yields and good sequencing data
the GRE DNA quantum eyes kit uses to
queue pcr assays to query more than 40
genomic low side that are randomly
distributed in the genome so because we
are targeting more than 40 genomic loci
that are rambling randomly distributed
it gives us a good sense of the amount
of fragmentation that is present in in
those DNA samples and not only does it
give us a good quantification and
qualification of of the pcr that is
amenable to amplification but sorry the
DNA that is applicable to amplification
it also gives us guidance to rescue
those low quality DNA samples
specifically it's going to to give you
the appropriate amount of input DNA that
is needed for that specific sample if
you want to translate that DNA into
appropriate library or fragments and in
NGS sequencing data it also it also
gives you the appropriate number of
targeted enrichment cycles that must be
used in your targeted enrichment step if
you want to be able to use that specific
sample that specific ffpe sample it for
sequencing and what this translates to
is it ensures reproducible high post
amplification yields because it is a
qpcr si it's a very simple setup whereby
the genomic DNA once it's isolated from
from FFPE samples or any of those low
low quality yielding samples the genomic
DNA is mixed with the qpcr essays and
master mix you run qpcr and through a
simple that analysis setup that is that
is available through kaijin on it you
actually get the amounts of DNA that are
amplifier both in in your sample and
also get this appropriate number of
targeted enrichment cycles that are
needed for that specific example to give
you to give you an example of how this
this kit can be used what we've done
here is we've run in 15 different
samples we've quantified that the DNA
from these samples by two different
methods spectrophotometry and qpcr using
optimized and we looked at next is the
library the library yield on the left
and the sequence specificity shown on
the right so when we look at the library
yield of those of those samples if they
were quantified by by by
spectrophotometry methods you can you
can see in the blue diamonds that the
library yield is pretty much all over
the place you get some that some samples
that have not given any that have not
yielded any library fragments whereas
some that have yielded you know some
library fragments but but not optimal
amounts of library fragments but if you
look at the same samples if they were
quantified by quantum eyes as shown in
these purple purple circles you do see a
pretty consistent library yield from
from the different samples remember
these are all these are 15 different
FFPE samples and because they were
quantified by quantum eyes using a qpcr
approach we were able to accurately
quantify the DNA resulting in
inconsistent library yields from these
15 different meh 15 samples when we look
at the sequence specificity so these are
the specificity of reads that are coming
out of the NGS NGS run on a my seat we
can also see some major differences
between those DNA samples that were
quantified by spectrophotometry versus
those that were quantified by quantum
eyes and you can see a very high degree
of specificity for for those reads that
are coming off the samples that were
quantified by quantum eyes as you can
see in the blue circles versus the blue
diamonds where those were those DNA
fragments were quantified by
spectrophotometry so again it is really
it's a very helpful a kit in order to
quantify the amplifier amount of DNA so
now that you've quantified your DNA the
next step would be to enrich for
specific genes and this webinar is
focused on bracket one bracket 2 but the
same the same principles can be applied
for other genes in the human genome what
we have done is we've taken advantage of
the multiplex PCR based system to
to allow us to design primers against
these specific genes that you want to
enrich again because this is a bracket
one bracket to webinar I'm going to use
the example of rock along bracket two
genes so with with targeted enrichment
the major challenge is that you want to
sequence every base within your targeted
region with look at little amounts of
DNA and that's that that led us to the
development of the gene read dna-seq are
gated back panels version 2 they use a
multiplex PCR based in Richmond so
instead of using a hybridization based
approach followed by pcr we go straight
to PCR to enrich for the genes it
provides so with with the with the kits
or with the panels we provide primer
sets for any region any gene or any set
of genes in the human genome so you can
define the the region the way the way
you you need to according to your to
your requirements that could be you know
entire genes it could be just certain
exotic regions of genes it could be
specific introns or promoter regions and
so on and so forth the the panels will
provide overlapping primers and those
primers are divided into an appropriate
number of pcr pools in the case of the
bracket one bracket to panel that i will
focus on today they have been divided
into four pcr pools so when i talk about
a panel it's basically a collection of
primers in in pcr pools so why did we
choose the multiplex pcr based targeted
enrichment approach there are two major
approaches for for targeted enrichment
you have the multiplex pcr based
approach and then you have the
hybridization based approaches each one
has its advantages and disadvantages but
the reason the main reason why we
decided to choose the multiplex PCR
based approach is because of the
specificity and uniformity of PCR that
cannot be matched by other targeted
enrichment approaches this was nicely
highlighted in a Nature's nature methods
paper that was published back in 2010
that actually compared to the different
targeted enrichment approaches from from
from multiplex pcr to hybrid capture or
MIPS if you're interested I highly
recommend going through this paper it is
has done an excellent job of comparing
the different the different methods but
but really what one of the conclusions
that came out of this paper is that the
specificity and uniformity of pcr for
target the enrichment cannot be matched
by any other by any other approach and
that is the reason why we decided to go
with a multiplex PCR based targeted
enrichment approach for our panels so
we've developed a 15 different cataloged
panels again just to remind you the
panels are basically a collection of
primers that target specific genes or or
regions of interest so that 15 different
panels that we have developed have
different applications so you have we've
developed some for solid tumors like the
clinically relevant humor in the tumor
actionable mutations panel we've
developed a panel for HIPAA panel for
hematologic malignancies which is the
myopia plasmas panel we've developed
nine other tissue specific panels for
you know for breast cancer colorectal
cancer liver cancer and so on and so
forth as you can see on this slide and
we've also developed comprehensive
panels in the form of cancer
predisposition panel the comprehensive
cancer panel and the carrier testing
panel you also have the option of
building your own custom panel so you
have two different ways by which we can
construct your your custom panel
depending on on what types of targets
you're interested in targeting but
today's focus is on Braca one and
bracket 2 and Tyson has also developed a
bracha one bracket to targeted panel
that specifically enriches for the
exonic regions of bra colon and bracket
tube now where did the content of these
panels come from it came from different
databases we've tapped into multiple
databases to build this to build the
contents for these panels from the
Cancer Genome Atlas to cosmic to even
private databases such as the ingenuity
systems so a lot of databases have been
tapped in order to build the content of
these panels and all of these panels
except for the custom panels have been
what bench tested in
the lab in house here so zooming in or
zooming into onto the bracket one
bracket two panels so as I mentioned
that this this panel is specific to the
exonic regions of Recca one bracket to
it has a lot of neat features and in
benefits it the amount of input DNA
needed is very minimal you only need 14
anagrams of DNA so even if you're
working with FFPE samples or these other
other types of samples that yields very
low amounts of DNA you can still enrich
for your genes using this panel it
utilizes an overlapping amplicon design
so all the the amplicons that that we
design our are overlapping to maximize
the coverage for for all the different
exotic regions in bracket one bracket to
in eight hours you can construct your
libraries and be the other feature of
this tunnel is that it yields one
library per per sample you're not
constructing libraries from each
individual pcr pool what you end up at
what you end up doing is you run your
PCR in four pools but then you end up
pulling all these applicants together
going into the library preparation step
so so although you're enriching using
four pools what you end up with is just
one library per sample which cuts down
on your costs now looking at some
specifications it has a one hundred
percent coverage for every single base
in the exonic regions of rekelen and
bracket to not only do we target the
exonic regions but we also target some
intronic regions to cover the intron
exon Junction so we recover on average
about 20 bases of around around each
exon so going to recover the exonic
regions plus some of the intronic
regions to get that intron exon junction
there are twenty-one thousand close to
21 520 1500 bases covered by this panel
the average amplicon length is 150 basis
so the amplicon length is also an
extremely important feature the
amplicons are small enough to make them
compatible with FFPE samples the number
of
or pools is is for so again as I
mentioned you will enrich your your DNA
samples in for pcr setups but then you
end but what you end up doing is pulling
all these primers or applicants to
generate only one library per sample 40
nano grams of DNA is is needed the
number of amplicons needed to cover all
the exon equations of brockton and
bracket or is 250 so it's still a fairly
small panel that that gives you the
power of high multiplexing so if you
want to run many more samples on an NGS
run you can easily do so because the
targeted region and the number of
amplicons is small it has a high degree
of specificity and uniformity so we're
seeing you know 99 percent percent
specificity which means that 99% of the
amplicons that are generated are
specific to the targeted regions that we
wanted to target which is basically
brought Colin and bracket to uniformity
is very high so it allows you to make to
make better use of your sequencing
capacity so you're not really wasting a
whole lot of sequencing capacity on
unwanted or onion form regions and the
percent of basis called is one hundred
percent so we're covering every single
base in the index sonic regions as well
as those 20 base pairs around the exotic
regions of bracket one bracket tube and
this is since we are talking about a
tumor suppressor gene or tumor
suppressor genes it is important to
cover every single base because as
opposed to oncogenes which which have
mutations in certain hotspots tumor
suppressor genes tend to accumulate
mutations across the entire length of
the of the gene or the coding regions of
the gene so when you're looking at tumor
suppressor genes it is extremely
important that you cover every single
base of those jeans so to give you an
example of the the overlapping nature of
the amplicons what you're looking at
here is just a snapshot of from from i
GV where I've where I've included the
the design of amplicons and I've
included some performance data on the
PGM as well as the my seek so what
you're looking at here you're looking at
the beaker
courage of this specific exon of bracket
one in the na 12 878 DNA sample so this
is the genome in a bottle sample that is
being developed as a standard for NGS
runs so we've enriched bracket 1 and
bracket 2 on from this DNA and we've
sequence the libraries on a PGM we've
also processed DNA from ffpe sample and
we also process the DNA from the na 12
878 sample and constructed libraries for
sequencing on a my seat so again what
you're looking at here is just an
example of how the amplicons are
overlapping for this specific bracket 1
x on and the same is true for all the
other excellence in bracket 1 and
bracket 2 and i'll show you in the next
couple of slides how the performance of
this panel looks like on a PG mmm I see
so for bracket 1 what I'm showing you
here is how the different excellence of
Braca one are covered by by this panel
on two different samples and two
different sequencers again the na 12 878
on a PGM and FFP sample on a PGM and the
na 12 878 DNA on em I seek we can see
coverage of every single base across the
different exons of bracket one and the
same is true for bracket 2 as i will
show you on the next slide and not only
that where we do see a very high degree
of uniformity across the different the
different exons of a fractal 144 this
slide here which again which which
allows you to sequence you know to
sequence your samples to a specific
specific depth of coverage you don't
have to go very very high to account for
for these loli loli covered regions a
high degree of uniformity as you can see
over here allows you to be more flexible
with you with your with your DNA with
your sequencing coverage so here's
coverage for the four bracket to again
what you're looking at is one hundred
percent coverage of all the exonic
regions of bracket to with a very high
degree of uniformity also and actually
you can see on on this slide over here
how there are many many amplicons tiling
across each other to cover a specific
exon again that goes back to the
overlapping nature of
fee of the amplicons to maximize the
coverage across the regions that you
want to cover and it also shows you the
high degree of uniformity across
different samples so again we've used
this na 12 878 DNA which is being
developed as a reference and it is it's
considered high quality DNA so with
high-quality DNA we can get excellent an
excellent degree of uniformity and also
when we look at FFPE samples we still
get a high degree of uniformity even
with those with you know low-quality DNA
so what are using high quality DNA or
low quality DNA you can still get pretty
good enrichment for the bracket one
bracket two genes using the bracket one
bracket tool panel okay so um I
mentioned the importance of covering
every base in bracket one and bracket 2
because they are tumor suppressor genes
now anyone was done sequencing with
amplicons understands the challenges of
sequencing the ends of amplicons the
ends of amplicons in next-generation
sequencing tend to be problematic
regions because because some of the
bases towards the ends of amplicons do
not get sequenced it's just the nature
of of how sequencing works for amplicons
so it is important to to protect the
ends of those applicants and in order to
accurately call variants near the ends
of those of those applicants or reads
primer sequences have to be present for
read napping and alignment so we use a
multiplex pcr based approach that
utilizes primers that will span or cover
the region that we're interested in and
we'll use those those primers to
basically amplify that region that we're
interested in now those primer sequences
they are not native to the sample so you
cannot use them to call variants within
those regions but you want to keep them
you want to keep those primer sequences
intact while you're mapping and
alignment your wii and aligning your
reads because basically those those
primers are now going to protect the
ends of the amplicons so you can
actually get those one or two bases that
are part of the amplicon but sit at the
end of it so if you have the primer
primer sequences
intact and take take that reads
throughout sequencing with the primer
sequences you end up protecting those
the ends of the amplicons which allows
you to call variants that are present
within those within the ends of the
amplicons approach is that died just
after the primer sequence can end up
with with false positives and negatives
as I will show you in be in the next
slide in a paper that was published
earlier this year but the concept of of
these blind spots towards the ends of
the amplicons have been described by our
our group here in a paper published late
last year in BMC genomics where they
actually describe the importance of
keeping primer sequences up until the
variant calling step so you do not you
do not call variants within the primer
sequences but you want to keep them on
on the ends of the amplicon so you can
protect the ends of the amplicons and
allow every single base to be sequenced
now this was very nicely actually shown
in a paper that was published earlier
this year from a from a group in Germany
who has who wanted to do a comparison
between the different PCR or multiplex
PCR based approaches so they used a a
panel from from from another another
vendor that does not die that does
digest the the primer sequences before
before the the library construction step
compared to our workflow that does not
digest the primer sequences and we keep
them all the way until the primer the
variant calling step and we softly clip
those primer sequences off the readings
so we don't call any variance but we
carried the primer sequences throughout
the entire reaction or the entire
workflow so what this group wanted to do
is to just compare the two different
approaches and on am I see so they would
prepare libraries from the Asian
workflow or the gene read sample to
incite work for versus versus the
workflow from from a plus seek and what
what they noticed at the one day when
they looked at the data is that the
sensitivity of the cajon panel is much
higher than that of
valpo see simply because the sum of the
variants that that were not detected so
there were five variants that were not
detected 69 out of 74 were detected and
five out of 74 was not detected it turns
out that these five these five variants
that were not detected they were they
they were at the amplicon boundaries and
primer binding sites which indicates
that the physical removal and digestion
of the primer of the primer sequences
will actually expose the ends of the
amplicons and what you end up with is
false negatives or false positives
towards these end of the amplicons
because they were not sequenced
efficiently so because they are two key
to tumor suppressor genes what you want
is to sequence you want to sequence
every single base in those in those two
genes and the gene read DNA seek bracket
one bracket to count gives you that one
hundred percent coverage in the coding
regions of every single base in indy and
the bracket one in bracket two genes and
i will show you actually examples as i
get to the applications data of of how
some customers have used the bracket one
bracket do panel to look at to get one
hundred percent coverage but it is a
universal panel in the sense that you
can use it for any for any sample or any
or on any major sequencer so as long as
you can get enough DNA as long as you
can get 40 nano grams of DNA whether it
is an ffpe sample a plasma sample liquid
biopsy or single cell as long as you can
get 40 nano grams of DNA you can use the
gene read DNA cpanel to enrich for
bracket one bracket to anything you can
sequence the libraries on the you know
platforms from from alumina as well as
platforms from ion torrent now sample
preparation is only one part of this you
need powerful data analysis and
interpretation tools and to build that
that sample to incite a solution kaijin
offers two major data analysis tools and
interpretation one is the CLC bio
medical genomics workbench as well as
the
annuity variant analysis for data
interpretation the CLC bio medical
genomics workbench is a base it's an
easy to use and end-to-end solution in
the sense that it's basically windows
that you can build and put together to
construct your workflow it has a plug-in
for the gene read DNA seek panels so
again because it is amplicon based
sequencing it needs a specific set up
within the data analysis tool and to
make things a lot easier on for our
customers we built this plug-in into the
CLC bio medical genomics workbench to to
make the analysis of amplicons much
easier so you get these you can you can
do mapping and alignment and even
visualize the variance and covariance
and even visualize them with the CLC bio
medical genomics workbench now once
those once those variants have been
called by the CLC by a platform what you
could do is take all that all that data
and and process it through the ingenuity
databases it through the ingenuity
variant analysis platform this is a
platform that is it's basically a
knowledge base that is 15 years in the
making a lot of a lot of people have
contributed to this to this knowledge
base it's a they've looked at they look
at all the publications that exist on
bit out there and have taken all that
knowledge and and have dumped it into
this into this tool so it's it's really
a huge database of all the variants that
have been reported in the literature so
what you'll do is you'll take those
those variants that have been detected
by and called by the CLC by a platform
and put it into IV a just to start
making sense of these variants so if you
see that Kos mutation in your sample
what does it mean from a biological and
clinical perspective and not only does
it tap into the ingenuity knowledge base
but it also taps into hgmd also so just
to kind of go through some some
performance and application data again
the first the first example I want to
show is from from routine testing so you
can use this bracket one bracket to to
panel for routine testing of samples but
before I get into this I kinda
want to just show you am or go through a
brief sort of introduction to the
different applications that one can do
for for for the the different panels
using NGS we know that you can do you
can look at the applications in two
major in two mates to two ways you have
detection and discovery the clinical
research area generally tends to to want
to do more detection where you know they
want to detect those those mutations
that are known to be actionable when we
look at translational and discovery
research there's a lot more discovery
they're interested in in knowing more
about their samples now there's each one
again has its its advantages and
disadvantages if you're looking at a
detection type of application because
the the target size tends to be small
again you're looking at those actionable
mutations you can do a very high degree
of multiplexing in the discovery side of
applications your target size generally
tends to increase so you're multiplexing
capabilities decrease so you look at a
lot more your multiplexing capabilities
decrease if you're looking at less
targets your multiplexing capabilities
increase so again but you could use you
could use panels to to look at you know
for clinical research as well as
translational research and that's these
are the two examples that will show you
today I'm going to show you how some
customers have used the bracket one
bracket to panel for clinical research
for mainly again routine testing whereby
they're interested in detecting known
mutations that exist in bracket one
bracket too but also how some customers
have used Braca one bracket one bracket
to containing panels for translational
purposes and when I when I talked about
a bracket one bracket to containing
panel it's basically a panel that has
the same gene designs that are contained
in the bracket one bracket to panel the
difference here is that you have
additional targets additional genes that
the customers interested in targeting so
to focus first on the clinical research
and the routine testing aspect of
bracket one bracket 2 so this this first
study is from from from dr.
Manos group in in Italy basically the
goal here was to verify the the presence
of a bracha one and bracket two
mutations in blood samples for from
hereditary breast cancer cases so six
samples were analyzed five blood samples
and one control genomic DNA the samples
were enriched for bracket one and
bracket to using the gene we GNA c panel
and then subjected to PGM sequencing
using disguising workflow and so looking
at the sequencing metrics we were seeing
the same exact sequencing metrics that
we see internally we see a very high
degree of specificity and uniformity and
every single base in bracket one and
bracket two were called in these in
these samples and when we look at the
different mutations that were detected
basically there are certain mutations
that were previously detected by Sanger
sequencing we were able to call every
single one of these mutations that have
been described by Sanger sequencing in
these samples however when when the when
the same in the same samples were run by
a different multiplex PCR based
enrichment approach specifically the amp
with seek workflow we know that from the
customer we know that be some of these
these mutations were not detected in the
in the samples where they should have
been detected so basically because again
we are covering every single base in
brokol one bracket two were able to call
some of these mutations that were not
called by the amplitude panel and just
drawing from from dr. no Manos testimony
here on the complete coverage provided
by the bracket one bracket to panel
allowed us to detect mutations that were
missed by other targeted enrichment
technologies again the complete coverage
of bracket one bracket to is is needed
because these are tumor suppressor genes
and you want to be able to call every
single base in them the second study is
this from a group in from dr.
boutonnieres group in in Cologne in
Germany and again the idea here was the
same is to verify the bracha one bracket
to panel performance but the difference
here is that the samples that were used
in the study or FFPE samples and the
sequencing was done on on on my seat so
looking at how the
again how the the different mutations
could be called by the ampulla stick
panel as well as the gene week panel
what the what the customer has done here
is they've run three runs run one and
two on the using the ampliphi work for
and then one for using the gene we
workflow so run for was basically a
repeat of run one and two the difference
is just the workflow that was used we
have 44 samples that were interrogated
35 ovarian cases and 99 memory or breast
cancer cases and again the idea here was
to compare the different multiplex pcr
based approaches so when they when the
when the authors looked at the the
number of mutations that can be detected
in bracket 1 and bracket 2 they were
they were seeing that four out of 21
mutations could not be called in bracket
to using the a plastic workflow again
simply because not every base is covered
in the india bracha one bracket to
embassy panel however when you look at
the how the gene read DNA seek Cano turn
back I wanna break it to you do see a
hundred percent on coverage and one
hundred percent concordance with what
has been previously known about these
samples so 60 out of 60 mutations in
bracket one were called and 21 out of 21
mutations for bracket you were called a
high degree of uniformity so we know
that more more than seventy percent of
the amplicons show more more than one
thousand reads which is very high
especially if you're if you're
interested in calling low frequency
mutations and as a matter of fact the
the frequency mutation that can be
called is as low as 5 percent so even if
you're even if the mutations that you're
interested in our present at a five
percent frequency you can still use that
workflow to call these types of
mutations so the last example that I
want to go through is a how you can use
the bracket one bracket eugene designs
for your bio marker studies specifically
for disease stratification in clinical
trials so again this is an example of
how you can use the bracket one bracket
to gene designs for for translational
research
now just to give you some background it
is known that that the current prostate
cancer treatments do not address the
heterogeneity of the disease so it is
known that prostate cancer is a very
heterogeneous cancer that has you know
different so you can call them different
subtypes of cancer within that same
family of of prostate cancer in that
molecular stratification based on
genetic aberrations can address the
heterogeneity of prostate cancer so
instead of looking at prostate cancer as
just one big disease the idea here is to
use molecular stratification to to try
to define those little subsets of
prostate cancer and treat them
differently now what is needed or
biomarker studies that can link the
treatment response to these genetic
compositions of the different forms of
prostate cancer and we know that bracket
mutational status has recently been
linked to responses Department abish and
this is exactly what I was talking about
earlier about elaborate it was it's
known that the mutational status of a
bracha can actually help us in in these
molecular stratification so we can we
can look at the bracket one and two
mutant brisket ovarian cancer samples in
a different way than those that have
wall type and and we know that bracket
the bracket genes are tumor suppressor
genes and that are involved in the DNA
repair machinery so the question here
that that the authors wanted to do in
this paper they hypothesized that DNA
repair defective prostate cancer is more
sensitive to pop inhibition than DNA
repair impact prostate cancer this paper
was published just this last week in the
New England Journal of Medicine it's an
excellent paper because it was a it's a
phase 2 clinical trial that actually
stratified patients based on this on the
genetic makeup of 113 genes but so the
idea here was was to build on the
earlier studies that I've showed for
ovarian cancer where the the authors are
asking me this question do we see the
same happening in prostate cancer or not
when these patients are treated with
with elaborate and in order to do so
they developed a biomarker list that
that can be used to predict these
responses to elaborate interface
clinical trial they used a list of 113
genes commonly apparent in in prostate
cancer and these rooms they fall mainly
within the DNA repair a class of genes
including bra colon and bracket 2 so
when they looked at the progression free
survival of of the of the different of
the different patients and they classify
the different cases into biomarker
positive prostate cancer and end or
biomarker negative prostate cancer and
when they looked at those those cases
that have been treated with a lab prep
they were seeing a higher
progression-free response rate compared
to the two those cases that were treated
with a leopard but they were but that
were vile marker negative with a highly
statistically which was highly
statistically significant and when they
looked at the different types of genes
that have been shown to be mutated in
these samples if you look at the list of
genes you'll see that the majority of
them if not all of them fall within that
DNA repair machinery list of genes so
you see a lot of mutations in bracket
one and bracket 2 in in check to an ATM
in FA MCA and healthy to and HTF 2 and
so on and so forth but basically those
that fall within this this
classification or the signature of of
these these response genes you see that
these patients respond more favorably if
they have mutations in there in those
jeans compared to those that do not have
mutations in those jeans so to close
this off with a with a summary basically
the bracket 1 and bracket to panel of
that occasion has built delivers one
hundred percent coverage of all the
bases it delivers outstanding sequencing
metrics 99% specificity specificity and
ninety-eight percent uniformity as
defined by a point to X on the mean it's
a streamlined workflow with integrated
data analysis and biological
interpretation so not only do you you
get to prepare your samples with a high
degree of specificity and uniformity but
also you can get to you get to analyze
the data with powerful tools and
biological interpretation as well the
bracken one bracket to panel is ideal
for the detection of both hereditary
somatic mutations we know that both are
important for from from from a cancer
perspective and you can use the same
panel for for hereditary and somatic
mutations and you can use the same panel
for the four different types of samples
including FFPE samples the blackra1n
bracket to gene designs regardless of
the tunnel can be used for different
applications and clinical and
translational research I've given you
examples of how you can use it for
routine testing wherever I you know
you're only your screening or you're
looking for specific mutations known
mutations in your in your samples on but
you can also use the same gene design
whether it is in the bracket one bracket
to panel or an extended panel like the
the panel that that contained 113 jeans
you can use the same the same gene
designed for different applications in
clinical as well as translational
research so I want to thank you again
for attending this webinar and I will
turn it now back to soon
thank you dr. Samara for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
questions session I would like to remind
our audience jumped from the question
you could submit questions by typing
them in the Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can the first question
is dr. Samara our brca1 and brca2 genes
involved in other cancers yes and the
matter of fact there was a recent paper
that was published in the new england
journal of medicine that should help
lackawanna cracka to and other gene
repair gia other DNA repair genes are
also involved in prostate cancer as well
ok the second question someone ask is
can the pan will be used for liquid
biopsy the panel can be used for liquid
biopsies because it is generates small
amplicons so it is very compatible with
the fragmented nature of liquid biopsy
DNA wait and what depth of coverage is
recommended for this panel um the depth
of coverage is going to depend on the
application we usually recommend 200x if
the user is interested in looking at
germline mutations and you recommend
anywhere between a thousand and fifteen
hundred exits or for somatic mutation
jim james be added to the panel the
panel by itself is a fixed panel however
you can take the design of the bronco
and and bracket to panel and use them in
a custom design where you can add as
many genes as you want up to maybe 160 g
very nice and we have time for one last
question it's nice presentation on to
tomorrow the reference debate that looks
fair wondering about the ingenuity
systems background is it based on
language evening
on the ingenuity system database is a
manually curated database it's been
curated over the past 10 years or so so
it's rob a lot of informative drug its
information from all the publications
that exist in in ncbi but it also does
some information from a lot of death
abated that already exists like the
cousins yesterday sorts for the twins
our database and so on and so forth hey
there are no more questions I'd like to
know once again same Duchess matter for
his presentation do you have any final
comments I mean the just as a final
comment the bracha one bracket two genes
are becoming very popular when it comes
to ovarian and as well now prostate
cancer research we know that they are
heavily involved in in responses to
specific therapy like the parp
inhibitors so I mean anything
determining the mutational landscape of
Recca one rekha to in specimens from
ovarian cancer as well as prostate
cancer will be very important well thank
you so much for your presentation
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for six months in
today's wide eight November 11 2015 you
will receive an email from library to
learning you in this webcast is
available for replay we invite you to
for that amount into your colleagues who
may have missed today's web event see
you next time goodbye
you
you